[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
peter king football morning in america
must read column
nbcsports.com pete joins us now pete the
oddest game of the weekend was turned in
by who
i would say the cleveland browns
uh
i was stunned at
the relative incompetence of the browns
i mean we all love the browns going into
this year i don't know anybody who
thought that they were going to be lousy
and who knows they might not be lousy
but they're lousy right now
and that really surprises me now some of
that has to be due to baker mayfield's
physical health i get it but
regardless of that they've just not been
good and i think
you know last night when i was just
fiddling around a little bit i was
looking at the standings and the one
thing about the standings this morning
that really surprises me
the cleveland browns have surrendered
more points than they have scored
i mean that just seems impossible to me
but hey every week in the nfl and dan
look you talk about predictions
the one thing i will always remember
about our time together at nbc
in that in that viewing room when we
would sit together for years and watch
the games
every
sunday at about 12 50
p.m
you would come out with your upset of
the day yeah
and i swear
you were right about 7 out of every 10
games it was uncanny it was ab like a
couple of weeks ago you would have said
i like the jets over the bengals and we
would have all said you're out of your
freaking mind and yet you would have
been right now you weren't right all the
time that's impossible but that's that
is a little bit of a skill that you have
that not many people do
i just don't know what to buy into now
like is there's if these were stocks
these teams were stocks
are you buying into the cowboys
i'm buying the patriots
oh
i'm definitely buying the patriots now
am i buying the patriots to play in
february no
i mean they might i don't know whether
they will or they won't but
i'm buying the patriots because i think
in recent weeks
they have played
so well defensively
and they have a quarterback who week
after week after week
yeah i said this to somebody the other
day on some talk show or other and i
said you know he's far and away the best
rookie quarterback in football and it's
not even close they say wait a second
you know he's on a better team than
trevor lawrence or justin fields i said
i mean would you have said that
on labor day weekend
maybe part of the reason he's on a
better team is because he's better
and uh
you know he's i think he's been terrific
but if you look at what they have done
defensively
uh and how many weapons they have on
defense like i named kyle duggar one of
my defensive players of the week this
week
but as i said in my thing i could name
10 patriots
so many guys are having an impact on
defense on this team
and you know if you look at the patriots
it's another thing they've outscored the
opposition by 98 points now
so
i mean this is this is not any flukey
thing
and you know the other thing about the
patriots i was not a big fan of paying
big money
to matthew jude on because the ravens
usually know
when to hold them when to fold them and
they usually fold them and they're
usually right
matthew juden is a force of nature
and uh so i don't know i think the
patriots are are going to be
uh hard to eliminate this year yeah i
think their playoff team um
with what you saw with the chiefs
against the raiders is that more about
the raiders or more about the chiefs
uh no i think it was i think it's
definitely a little bit of both
uh
i think
that
not necessarily on the field but off the
field there has to be some sort of
impact with everything that's happened
to them
this is a franchise that's absolutely
totally adrift
uh and derek carr has played two games
in a row where you say now that's one of
the reasons why we don't call him a top
10 quarterback
i mean he's gone from being a legitimate
guy who's in the discussion for mvp to
say why did he just throw that ball
three feet over that guy's head
um and and look everybody has bad games
everybody has slumps i still think derek
carr is pretty good but
i mean he's been bad the last two weeks
um
i think but i i mean i talked to patrick
mahomes after the game last night and i
came away feeling like
uh that the absolute unequivocal best
thing
about patrick mahomes
is that
you know he doesn't
think the sky is falling
and you know i i asked him last night
dan i said hey patrick i said
have you ever thought in the last month
when you probably know the outside world
thinks you guys are are you know are bad
and that it's over
and you have fallen to her do you ever
stare at the ceiling and say what's
wrong with me
and he goes
no i didn't
pause end of answer i mean you know and
and so
that's isn't that what you want in your
quarterback you want a quarterback who
is introspective and who says hmm
why isn't this working hey andy let's
sit down and talk about why it isn't
working and they did many times you know
what andy reid told patrick mahomes this
week before this game
hey listen take the check down if it's
there but be you
and isn't that what you want in your
coach don't you want that trust and
faith in your coach and look he's going
to have some rocky times it'd be totally
unnatural no quarterback who's ever
played
has had three years and multiply that
times
uh times five and that's your career for
the first three years it it can't happen
but i think he got everybody spoiled to
that fact but i thought he was terrific
last night what did you make of the
packers
and seattle game
dan
in my opinion uh i thought that
i mean as i wrote i said you know we
played a half a season of games and
there's few games if any
that have made so many loud statements
as that game
probably the loudest statement in that
game is that the green bay packers do
not need vintage aaron rodgers
to beat a good team and i still think
seattle's a good team they're not a
great team but they're a good team
and
and you know and look at what happened
with aj dylan aj dylan basically
was jim taylor in 1965
you know for those of us of a certain
age well i was only eight then but
you know he was a big back doing big
back things carrying bobby wagner into
the end zone and and then
what else do you make of it i mean you
also make of it that you really have to
question
uh
first of all whether they can respond
this year
and whether the seahawks in my opinion
should think i'm not saying they should
but should they think of trading russell
wilson for three ones and a good player
in march
i i mean i think
the automatic answer is absolutely
categorically not you don't trade a
great quarterback you don't do it well
if he's going to be really unhappy
uh and i'm not saying that he will be
but i'm saying that you shouldn't just
dismiss it out of hand john schneider
found russell wilson with the 77th pick
in the draft nine years ago
and i'm sure he has faith in his ability
to find another quarterback in the draft
i don't know if that'll happen truly
but that game
said a lot of it made a lot of bold
statements to me he's peter king
football morning in america is the
column to read nbcsports.com
uh how did how did this all play out
with the rams getting obj and and what
role do you think he plays tonight
i think he plays 10 to 20 snaps
they're gonna play
two
uh
one seventh round pick a receiver from
notre dame i forget the guy's name
uh and they're gonna play another guy
named j.j koski
uh you know these guys are not household
names in their own household and they're
gonna play tonight i think probably a
lot of snaps
i think the the the rams i think sean
mcvay is just a little bit concerned
about force-feeding too much it's like
what matt rule told me after the game
they yesterday they didn't decide what
to do with cam newton
until the morning of the game okay are
you comfortable if we put in
these plays you know there's only like
three or four plays that they that he
had practiced that he had studied that
he knew everything about are you
comfortable yeah okay then then let's
have him
have this in the game plan and newton
was perfect adam obviously he's done
those before but i think with odell
i think he might play a few snaps
just to kind of get his feet wet
but
this the
i don't think sean mcvay wants to force
him in before he's fully ready to play
then they got the bye
and then i think he'll be ready to be a
full-time participant
when they come back from the buy
how does this play out with john gruden
suing the nfl
i mean i doubt he'll win dan
uh it just you know this
reminds me so much of uh of what al
davis used to do with pete rozelle
uh you know the former raiders owner the
former nfl commissioner
al davis made it personal
john gruden is going to make it personal
as somebody who knows gruden told me
over the weekend
why not he's got nothing to lose he
knows he's not working in the game again
so he's going to lob molotov cocktails
at park avenue
uh and he doesn't care who's hurt in the
process how about him he just woke up
one day and all of a sudden
he wasn't the coach of the raiders
anymore
you know and
it reminds me what george young the
general manager used to of the giants
used to say when when we would talk to
him about one controversy or another and
he goes i'm just over here picking my
nose and i get in trouble now obviously
gruden did something to cause that so
i'm not saying certainly that he's
blameless but i think he just feels
right now dan
why not throw everything up against the
league and see if we can make something
stick but i continue to say
in my opinion
it's it's senseless
to think that the league released these
uh these emails now
you know somebody connected with the
league who who knows i don't have any
idea who did it honestly
but it doesn't strike me as logical to
think that they would release emails
that would really besmirch the
reputation of their chief legal counsel
jeff pasch who everybody in that in that
office loves so i i would be surprised
if he would win the lawsuit i just
has anybody come up with any logic that
they knew this
in the summer
they knew these emails existed with john
gruden but they kept
then they brought him up
during the season
but
would they have brought them up
would they have brought them up
if
uh there wasn't noise about them leaking
that's the question to answer
i think it was a thursday night when
andrew beaton of the wall street journal
called the raiders might have been
wednesday i forget when it was exactly
and then by monday gruden was gone i'm
just not sure that the nfl would have
released
uh or would have
you know would have sent those emails to
the raiders
at that time
you know maybe they would have done it
at another time and maybe you could
argue that hey they should have
gone out and presented to mark davis all
the evidence they had in june
and said what do you want to do about
this and what he would have done i don't
know but that is a justifiable criticism
on the nfl
you know they basically let the emails
sit there and percolate and then somehow
someway they got in the hands of the
media
and that's when all heck broke loose
i'm
guessing that urban meyer is
okay in jacksonville they they put up a
good fight and he had a pretty good
month considering what happened prior
to that um
but jacksonville played the colts you
know they went toe-to-toe what do you
make of the jags moving on uh second
half of the season
well dan
they've
won two games
in the last among the last four they're
two and two
you know they got beat up by seattle and
they brought indianapolis right to the
end
uh
i would doubt sincerely
at all
that uh shad khan
who has placed a lot of faith in urban
meyer to fix this
uh that he's having any thoughts of
moving on i'm sure that urban meyer
barring
something weird and again i say barring
something weird because with urban meyer
there might be something weird there has
been something weird already so
but no i don't think he's in any danger
uh as long as things continue sort of
the way they are
pete always good to talk to you we
appreciate your time as always thank you
buddy
okay dan thank you that's peter king
football morning in america and of
course a contributor to nbc sports
football night america